the date is set and a six-week campaign
for Australia's Federal elections
officially begins there's fire there's
pandemic there is now War
prime minister Scott Morrison is seeking
re-election his conservative Coalition
has held power since 2013 but Morrison
is the first Australian prime minister
to serve a full term in more than a
decade it's a choice between a strong
future and an uncertain one
it's a choice between a government you
know
and a labor opposition that you don't
our government is not perfect we've
never claimed to be
but we are up front his Challenger the
center left labor party leader Anthony
Albanese he has a message of optimism
growing up with the single mum I learned
the value of a dollar and I sleeped
heavily in its work in class routes more
jobs Better Health Services and cheaper
child care I will lead with integrity
and I will treat you with respect
I will restore faith in our political
system by ending the waste and rots and
establishing a strong National
anti-corruption commission albanese's
campaign will focus on trust in the
government or lack of it
the past three years have been dominated
by catastrophic bushfires devastating
floods and some of the world's toughest
covid-19 rules
the answer is lies in Scott Morrison's
personal appeal and standing and level
of trust in the annual barometer a poll
of who's the country's most and least
trusted politicians last month Scott
Morrison was rated the least trusted
politician in the country and the
opposition leader Anthony Albanese was
rated the second most trusted while
Morrison will Bank on strong economy the
government budget is nearly one trillion
dollars in debt Morrison's refusal to
commit to phasing out fossil fuels has
also galvanized green activists and
independent candidates who can hurt his
coalition
[Music]
and then they are worsting ties with
China which the government has been
accused of weaponizing
but Scott Morrison is known for pulling
off political successes before despite
significant odds Priyanka Gupta Al
Jazeera